Роками Європа перебувала на гачку Росії через викопне паливо.
У 2021 році 40 відсотків газу до ЄС надходили з РФ.
Більше половини експорту російської нафти призначалися для Європи.
А російські шахти безперервно постачали вугілля для європейських ТЕС.
В цілому у рік перед вторгненням РФ до України Європа придбала у росіян
викопного палива на сто мільярдів доларів.
Таким чином стаючи в залежність від країни-агресора і фінансуючи його.
Ще у школі нас завжди вчили не класти всі яйця в один кошик.
Це Фатіх Біроль, виконавчий директор Міжнародного енергетичного агентства -
організації за участі міністрів енергетики провідних країн світу.
Європа поклала усі яйця в один кошик - кошик зруйнували, а яйця розбилися.
Уже через тиждень після вторгнення команда Біроля склала план дій з 10 пунктів,
аби послабити залежність Європи від російського газу.
Він передбачав, зокрема, купівлю газу в інших країн, затримку закриття АЕС та посилене виробництво
сонячних панелей та вітрових турбін.
Серед рекомендацій  була і більш "брудна" опція - спалювати більше вугілля та нафти.
У своїй сукупності такі дії могли б удвічі скоротити потребу в російському газі до кінця 2022 року.
Тоді ж я провів розмови з лідерами урядів у Європі. Вони вважали план занадто радикальним.
Але попри певну стриманість, Євросоюз взяв на озброєння більшість пропозицій.
Перше, що зробила Європа - замінила викопне паливо з РФ іншим.
ЄС закупив більше газу з Алжиру та Норвегії.
А також домовився про поставки зрідженого природного газу зі США та Катару.
А ще повернувся до джерела енергії, від якого клявся відмовитися.
Вугілля не має майбутнього!
Так запевняв головний представник з питань клімату на саміті 2021 року.
Тоді багаті країни, залежні від газу, зухвало переконували бідніші відмовитися від вугілля.
Однак після скорочення Путіним поставок газу в Європу, а станом на жовтень 2022-го майже повної їх зупинки,
ці країни почали знову запускати старі вугільні станції.
Утім, проблема полягала в тому, що Європа переживала енергетичну кризу не лише через Росію.
Європу охопила найгірша за десятиліття посуха.
Шалена посуха висушила річки Європи, тому ГЕС виробляли менше електроенергії.
У Франції головним джерелом струму залишалася атомна енергія,
але місцеві АЕС потерпали через проблеми з обслуговуванням.
Погіршувало ситуацію і те, що Німеччина та Бельгія
саме були в процесі відмови від виробництва атомної енергії.
Та зрештою Бельгія подовжила роботу АЕС на 10 років, а ФРН - на кілька місяців.
При цьому до кліматичних цілей Європи належало прагнення якомога швидше відмовитися
від вугілля аж до цілковитої відмови у 2030 році.
Натомість у 2022-му в ЄС спалили на сім відсотків більше вугілля, ніж у 2021-му.
Але це було лише першою несподіванкою європейської енергетичної кризи:
"камбек" вугілля став не таким масштабним, як прогнозували.
В останньому кварталі 2022-го 26 вугільних станцій, до експлуатації яких повернулися
на випадок крайньої необхідності, працювали лише на 18 відсотків своєї спроможності,
причому 9 з них взагалі не використали.
Тож поки Європа спалювала трохи більше вугілля,
найбільше торік зросли потужності вітрової та сонячної енергетики.
Сонячна енергія - королева енергоринків у всьому світі й наступниця старого короля - вугілля.
Європа не просто перейшла на інше викопне паливо, щоб замінити російський газ.
Вона прискорила свій перехід на чисту енергію.
У 2022 році ЄС встановив більше сонячних панелей та вітрових турбін,
збудував більше батарей та інсталював більше теплових насосів, ніж будь-коли раніше.
Єврокомісія підвищила свої цілі щодо частки відновлювальної енергії на 2030 рік -
з 40 до 45 відсотків.
А також полегшила умови спорудження необхідної для цього інфраструктури.
І все ж, європейські лідери неохоче вдалися до застосування одного доволі очевидного важеля -
зменшення використання енергії.
У середньому будівлі в Європі опалюються до температури 22 градуси за Цельсієм -
це значно більше, ніж потрібно для комфорту.
План дій МЕА вказував на те, що зниження температури хоч на один градус
зменшує потребу в газі на 10 мільярдів кубометрів.
Однак лише деякі уряди справді інвестували ресурси в публічні кампанії,
покликані змінити опалювальні звички людей.
Поза сумнівом, у Європі був більший потенціал для заощадження газу,
енергії у більших обсягах. Ми добре впоралися.
Але якщо ви запитаєте, чи на відмінно, то я скажу: ні!
Зрештою допомогли дві речі.
По-перше, високі ціни на газ та почуття солідарності з Україною спонукало багатьох людей менше опалювати.
Деякі країни на кшталт Німеччини знизили температуру в громадських будівлях.
Франція попросила своїх громадян опалювати домівки й офіси не більше,
ніж до 19 градусів, хоч і не запровадила відповідного контролю.
По-друге, ще більша несподівана підтримка для подолання кризи надійшла від… клімату.
Зима 2022 року стала другою найтеплішою зимою у Європі, відколи фіксують такі показники.
Тобто людям просто не довелося багато опалювати домівки.
Крім того, промислові підприємства скоротили виробництво,
застосувавши на 25 відсотків газу менше.
Загальна потреба в ЄС 2022 року впала до 50 мільярдів кубометрів газу -
найбільше падіння в історії.
Починаючи з вересня, потреба у струмі була незвично низькою.
Нам пощастило з теплою зимою.
Я наголошую на цьому, коли спілкуюся з урядами, бо наступної зими
нам не варто знову розраховувати на удачу й теплу зиму.
Тож наскільки серйозним є перехід Європи на зелену енергію?
Принаймні можна було б зробити більше, аби ще швидше відмовитися і від російської нафти.
Верхня цінова межа на російську нафту сьогодні набула чинності,
викликавши гнів Москви та додавши викликів глобальному нафтовому ринку.
Санкції запровадили лише в грудні 2022 року,
тож за минулий рік ЄС імпортував лише на 16 відсотків нафти менше, ніж у попередній рік.
Багато країн запровадили субсидії на пальне для водіїв замість того,
щоб допомогти людям відмовитися від авто чи купити електромобіль.
Непокоїть і те, наскільки великі ставки робляться на зріджений газ.
Країни, як Німеччина, в яких не було інфраструктури для отримання поставок,
затвердили будівництво значно більшої кількості терміналів, ніж  необхідно, вказують експерти.
Лише половина із запланованої Європою інфраструктури для зрідженого газу
ще буде потрібною у 2030 році.
Варто зауважити, що деякі європейські уряди уклали угоди щодо поставок газу
з країнами на кшталт Катару на щонайменше 15 років.
А це в принципі змушує засумніватися, чи засвоїли вони урок минулого,
коли надто покладалися на Росію.
Коли пил вляжеться, урядам Європи, включно з ФРН,
варто вдатися до самокритики, переглянувши власну енергетичну політику,
бо, на мій погляд, це було стратегічною помилкою з наслідками не лише для енергетики,
а й для зовнішньої політики.
Врешті-решт вторгнення Путіна в Україну зумовило переворот в енергетичній системі ЄС.
З одного боку, це примусило ЄС спалювати більше вугілля та купувати більше газу.
Таким чином завадивши європейцям виконувати власні кліматичні цілі,
які вони намагалися нав'язати іншим.
Водночас, оговтавшись від шоку, континент позбувся залежності він енергоносіїв з Росії.
А це не лише на короткий час дало поштовх переходу на відновлювані джерела.
Це призвело до глибших структурних змін, які прискорять перехід на зелену енергію.
Якщо експерти не помиляються, повернення до вугілля не буде тривалим,
а от різке зростання частки чистої енергії вже не зупинити.